Ukraine's President Vladimir zlinski is
visiting neighboring Poland to thank the
nation for its support since the Russian
invasion he arrived by train at the
Border Town of shamushul zelenski will
meet Ukrainian refugees after holding
talks with President Andre Duda many
ukrainians have fled to Poland since the
beginning of the war on day two of their
meeting in Brussels NATO foreign
ministers are discussing China's ties
with Russia they're concern that Beijing
is considering supplying arms to Moscow
Secretary General Jen stoltenberg also
wants NATO members to commit to spending
at least two percent of national income
on defense at a summit later this year
let's go live down to Ukraine's Capital
Kiev how to Serious Jonah Hull is there
so zielinski is in Poland Jonah an
important Ally what are we to make of
this visit
yeah president zielinski as you said
crossed the border early this morning on
a visit initiated by the Polish
presidency it was their invitation uh
that he come he's accompanied by his
wife or Leona which is substantially
unusual they don't always take these
trips uh together and the couple
projecting a sort of image and air of
some confidence on this visit uh to one
of Ukraine's closest allies of course
certainly it's geographically closest
Ally Poland has been hugely valuable to
Ukrainian coalescing international
support uh for Ukraine and in taking in
more than a million uh Ukrainian
refugees but it's not just about
deepening that Alliance it is also
although neither side explicitly says so
an opportunity to try and paper over
still fairly small cracks in the
alliance before they're allowed to get
any bigger notably to do with Ukrainian
grain Imports the European Union cheap
grain flooding into the European Union
tariff free bringing the price of grain
down It's upsetting farmers in a number
number of countries polish Farmers had
said they would try to disrupt this
visit that hasn't happened yet and in
point of fact during the last couple of
hours the Polish agriculture Minister
resigned while zelinski was there in
protest at the European commission's
decision to continue tariff-free access
for cheap Ukrainian grain into
2024. so it may not sound like a small
issue but I think an opportunity here to
do some diplomacy and make sure these
things aren't allowed to interfere with
the wider goal of European countries
helping Ukraine with the war
General as we said uh NATO foreign
ministers are meeting in Brussels uh
today do we expect more offers of
military assistance to Ukraine
well they've already come those offers
of military assistance from NATO allies
as you say in anticipation of what is
expected to be a Ukrainian
counter-offensive potentially any day
now thought possibly to take place uh in
the east of this country trying to
dislodge Russian positions around places
like Batman the headline announcement
from the United States a further 2.66
billion dollars worth of military aid
including air surveillance radar systems
anti-tank rockets and fuel trucks all
thought to be needed in advance of that
counter-offensive the Spanish have said
their offer of six leopard two tanks to
join dozens of others pledged by other
countries will be on the move towards
the second half of this month and Poland
again announced earlier this week that
it had already dispatched Mig aircraft
no specific number to that but had
already sent Mig aircraft to Ukraine
reporting live there from Kiev many
thanks indeed Jonah